Houston, soyez informé que le minecart Marwan est
toujours en vie
Je joue un gars nommé Mark Watney, il est
astronaute dans cette mission sur Mars cet
événement météorologique se produit et il se retrouve
bloqué et l'histoire suit vraiment
la quête de ce gars pour survivre
faisons le calcul cela prendrait quatre
ans  pour qu'une autre mission habitée
me rejoigne et je vais avoir conçu les
31 derniers jours,
c'est époustouflant de savoir comment vous
pourriez mourir de 99 000 façons différentes,
il doit avoir une atmosphère dans laquelle il peut
vivre et il doit avoir assez de nourriture
pour survivre, je dois trouver comment faire
pousser quatre ans de nourriture sur une planète
où rien ne pousse, il est botaniste
heureusement, alors il dit que j'aurais pu prendre
ce sol de Mars pour en faire un
environnement riche en nutriments dans lequel quelque chose pourrait
réellement pousser, mais alors vous avez  pour travailler
sur une sorte d'arrosage alors vous allez à
créer de l'eau bonne chose est que je connais la
recette ouais je me suis fait exploser j'aime l'
idée que ce film célèbre l'
intelligence et cet esprit de courage
que ces ast  les ronautes ont de l'espace ça
ne coopère pas je te garantis
qu'à un moment donné tu vas dire
c'est ça